moi je me disais il ya un nombre de
métiers dans le cinéma ouais et la
plaque qu'on récompense jamais ouais ça
donne à bouffer euros son
prix du meilleur cadre enchanteur too
fast pour ses incomparables travelling
dans le film l'intrigant de monter ce
clin venez quand nous en avons le temps
souffriez vous que je vous dise un petit
poème de sa composition ses folies et
mon coeur projet d'une telle audace en
folie êtes loin s'en faut faisant fi des
convenances et écoutez plutôt
à contempler longuement votre visage
conduit mon coeur votre coeur ont
pris des meilleurs effets spéciaux
mélanie vu ni connu dans le film moscow
burning
wilmots justice que ceux de spidey n'y
prix du meilleur doublage les frères
floués dans le film et il faut porter
assistance aux soldats andré r
non pierre
pierre
il monte andré je ne laisserai pas
mourir un ami pierre entendu hier bon
change de paris un front que nous
rentrons sain et sauf chez nous en
corrèze retrouver les gens que nous
aimons à riquier
le tour et tu t'en souviens mangeons une
bonne blanquette de boire un grand verre
de périers et pour sûr un bon grand
verre de perrier a tenu hier à ça tu
paries cette
pierre meyer
riz du meilleur perchiste jean pierre
dodo dans le film l'espion qui on savait
pas mal
alors je vais faire deux minutes pas de
quoi s'inquiéter
sans doute raison
mais restons discrets je n'aime pas cet
endroit et hollywoodienne qui pourra les
entendre
vous savez mes murs les murs ont des
oreilles
et là tu dis là je vous aime
ah bon